i'll just say this you know first of all
i'm not going to get into contract
specifics but aaron's our guy um he's
going to be our quarterback for the
foreseeable future we're excited about
you know kind of the things we're going
to try to accomplish here over the next
couple years so
um we certainly think that
you know with the contract that you're
kind of talking about is something we'll
work through we're going to have to do
probably a few things with different
contracts as we
as we head towards the season and
through the season to make sure that our
salary kept situation not only this year
but in
2022
is square so
we're not done yet we've done a lot to
get here
we've kind of been doing things as we go
and we will continue to do that as we go
ryan gooda koontz packers general
manager i'd love to know how much they
paid a consultant to come up with the
phrase foreseeable future i don't know
what that means do you know what that
means chris in this context no i don't i
you know i and i i mean
th this is going to be a conversation
we're going to talk about a lot during
the year i think for sure
but yeah i don't know foreseeable future
all that stuff there was a lot of things
i questioned in that press conference
there yesterday you know first off guten
coost was he was he was reeling right
away with these contract situations it
wasn't really a definitive answer either
it was kind of like we'll talk about it
we got to address it here here's what
i'm going to address with you green bay
your salary cap situation for 2022 will
be good because aaron rodgers won't be
there he's going to be on another team
so don't you worry you'll have plenty of
room to do all the things you need to do
he's gone this is it
aaron rodgers will be in green bay i'm
calling my shot now
now
chris i i firmly believe that at the
core
this is about the packers preserving
their ability
to to make a year-to-year decision on
aaron rodgers yeah and
and
by not restructuring his contract yet
they paid him a 6.8 million roster bonus
that all counts toward 2021 that could
have been spread over multiple years
they still haven't restructured his base
salary 14 million in change that could
be spread over multiple years the
problem with doing that is it makes the
cap charge next year if you trade him
before june 1 too high it ties your
hands in 2022 they want to see what does
he do in 21 we make a decision after 21
is he our guy in 22 what does he do in
22 make a decision after 22 is he our
guy in 23 they want that flexibility he
wants a commitment it's that simple
he wants more than a one-year commitment
and they're not giving it to him and i
don't think they're going to i don't i
don't i don't know if i agree with that
either i don't think he wants a
commitment i think he's done i think
it's you know sayonora see you later i'm
out of here i don't i think the
flustered of
guten kuz talking about the contract and
the extension and we have other
contracts we got to address during the
season for all that i think that's
because they've called rogers and his
camp and have gotten crickets on the
restructuring thing because
for all the reasons you're saying greed
bay wants to do one year thing rogers is
saying the same thing i want to get the
hell out of here after one year i don't
want to be tied here i'm done i just
think that i feel like the writing's on
the wall there i really feel like this
is where it's coming to and i don't
think we're going to hear any news about
them restructuring jack diddley squat
because i don't think that's going to
happen
i wouldn't disagree with you that that's
where he is now yeah i think back in the
middle of january when
the season ended and he gratuitously
veered toward that hey maybe i won't be
here next year and then a couple of days
later it's like don't oh what am i oh
well but did i do that yeah i mean he
likes doing that kind of stuff he lights
the fuse backs away the bomb goes off we
say hey a bomb went off and we're the
buttholes i almost said another word for
noting that the bomb went off but um but
but i i think he he then at that time
would have welcomed the certainty i i
think we now know we're in late april
right if he hasn't gotten the certainty
now he's not getting the circle that's
what i mean exactly right and so and so
it's one more year right and yeah the
packers want the flexibility but i agree
with you
and and look here's here's where
aaron rodgers has to step out of
character and i'll believe that he's
willing to do it when he does it he saw
what happened with brett favre yeah they
engineered brett favre's retirement now
they engineered it because he was
waffling about it year after year and
they finally decided to to nudge him
into retirement by asking him for a
definitive decision in a month when they
knew he would say well if i have to give
you a decision now i retire and then he
tried to come back
they didn't want him they wanted to turn
the page to aaron rodgers he got he
forced to trade he ends up with the jets
he ends up with the vikings he's public
enemy number one in green bay i think
aaron rodgers is trying to avoid that i
think when the time comes for him to
make his power play
he wants to be
certain or as close to certain as
possible that he's not painted as the
villain
and i don't i don't know i don't know
that he can pull that off maybe he can
maybe if he has another big year and he
does the paul cruz stick this in your
trophy case to mark murphy or whoever
maybe the fans get behind him and he
leaves town as a champion and the guy
who stuck it to the organization i just
i think that's going to be a tough
needle for him to threaten yeah i i
don't disagree with you there i don't um
i just i guess you know in my heart of
hearts feel like that time has come you
know for him to make that type of tough
decision and i think the other aspect
too that at least is a little
interesting that i do notice
is
i feel like public opinion has swayed
towards
roger's favor ever since the nfc
championship game a little bit to where
i think people looked at it were like
man he does all these awesome things man
he's awesome can somebody there help him
a little bit you know i think i think a
little bit like even the people who
don't love rogers i think came away with
that game a little bit feeling sorry for
rogers for maybe the first time ever and
i think people have also realized with
all the talk ever since the last year's
draft how little they've really done to
put high-end talent around him to where
i feel like in the the world of public
perception right now if he did to make
that type of move i think more a lot
more would favor him than green bay with
at least the optics of this situation
quick point matt casey whispered
something in my ear that i want to
address tom brady was able to leave new
england without the fan base turning on
it but he gave him 20 years right six
championships and it was at a point
where based on what we saw in 2019
you know the gas is kind of out of the
tank if they'd have known if they'd
known how much gas was still in the tank
they may have felt differently when he
walked away but i think he's transcended
that possibility of the fan base turning
on him in boston with aaron rodgers i
don't know and again he saw it happen
with brett favre i think that's what
he's concerned about yeah all right it's
a different situation you're right but
it's it's a good one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports